I'm helping to raise a 10 year old
sister and 16 year old brother
and I'm trying to date yeah and I'm like
it's really always
all of you yeah and not just you and
that person yeah who has time for love
when you're Savannah Chrisley I'm single
having fun I just want to find someone
who understands my life who understands
the things that I deal with and she's
dealing with a lot what we will not do
is we will not break her parents Todd
and Julie are serving a combined 19-year
prison sentence leaving Savannah to
parent her younger siblings Grayson and
Chloe
[Music]
I didn't hurt your Papa's feelings yes
she did Chloe the reality star gets into
it on her unlocked podcast
it's hard I'm helping to raise a 10 year
old sister and 16 year old brother
and I'm trying to date yep if you want
to get with Savannah Chrisley you might
meet the family on a first date what do
you do with them you know I'm like 16
year old adult you know he drives all
that but the 10 year old I'm like okay
well I mean you've got to maybe come
have dinner with me you've got it like
so from the beginning it's really always
all of you yeah and not just you and
that person I have raised thanking
children for that I'm blessed thinking
of mom and dad not being here during
certain life events and
it's like I can't in my mind I'm like I
can't move on with my life that Savannah
back in December just days before Todd
and Julie surrendered to prison until I
know that they're gonna be there yeah I
can't get married I can't have a kid
business-wise like I keep pushing
forward but personally
I feel like there's a level of guilt
associated with like moving on with my
life something else on her plate helping
Mom and Dad plead their innocence from
behind bars I think they're optimistic
and let me be clear I think that
optimism is well placed this trial was
riddled with heirs and we expect the
appeals court to see that I've never
seen two people my parents be so
steadfast in their faith in the end the
truth will prevail may get harder before
it gets easier but we have faith back to
her dating life Savannah has gotten
plenty of advice from her parents I've
always told my children to find someone
of like kind someone that they have you
know something in common with today
because of their notoriety I have to
tell them be careful of the people that
are here and for the reasons that
they're around you because you never
know if they're using you to climb up
and it doesn't matter if they have a
name or if they don't you know if they
understand it then great but not gonna
use me that's one thing you've got to
maybe come have dinner with me you've
got it like so from the beginning it's
really always
all of you yeah and not just you and
that person
[Music]